tentative fighting game segues Peter
Rosa Capcom hailed on going Combofiend
my friends thank you very much great
i'll be on the show knocks on McGee hey
back no maybe like lukewarm yes I got to
see you every day I want to a friend
Combofiend here only once whenever we do
things in Boston or whenever you've got
a street fighter game show yeah there
you go so thank you very much coming on
old street fighter 4 yeah come on hot at
the gate yes can you please kick max was
ass right now is that we're just going
into it oh yeah straight it Wow looks
good today tell us about what's coming
out what's new all right um I kick his
ass what you doing it that's what you
paid for right yeah I mean ass-kicking
is coming regardless okay oh yeah
there's going to be a consider about an
ass-kicking going yeah like I thought
that you know you wanted a segue into it
I don't know don't worry cuz we thought
we've got this fresh supply of asses
it's a kick oh okay keep in common oh
yeah there's plenty of times they shall
have everything so you guys are pretty
close to getting this bad boy in there
right yes yes it's coming out our early
June so we're definitely looking forward
to getting this in the players hands
finally after so many months so for the
folks who are not familiar with that
with this version of street fighter 4
just give the elevator pitch of what
exactly is in this game elevator did a
bunch of different games in one okay
crammed in there oh just read fighter
for balanced by the community for the
community five new characters for those
guys who want something new and exciting
six new stages you know just a lot of
new battle mechanics going into it it's
pretty much a street fighter 4
reinvented when you say balanced by the
community do you mean yourself because
you of course I had a massive Department
of the capcom unity the street fighter 4
community for a long time and you've
been with how come there for a year yeah
do you feel like this is kind of like
you giving back to the community or like
representing the community yeah this is
actually the first time that uh the fans
have been heard
you know they get to finally play the
character that they've always envisioned
yeah and I mean ultimately it was me who
went through all their changes to give
them what they wanted to see cuz some
people they were like just like my
character a superhuman character I just
wanna win with that whole p oh we can't
I do that but we definitely made a
character strong enough so this time
people can win to the hearts continues I
still murder Maxwell heart I give up and
ran the entire length of the stay yeah
and then murdered it yeah he did that to
you while doing his job oh well I mean
this is my job to get the alienated piss
off games price that's just one by one
Peter obviously some people may
recognize a few of our fighters here
from another recent kappa party yeah
yeah you know first they were in final
fight than they were in a fighter cross
tekken but in street fighter cross
tekken it's so much differently than
they do now I mean they had different
strengths that weaknesses over there
here um we tried to make sure that the
characters had a more plastic field so
if you play third strike Street Fighter
3 series that's where Hugo was really
really fun to play with right so we
tried to capture that essence you know a
poison and shoot fighter cross tekken
she was kind of a jack of all trades but
master of none and this we tried to
actually make her master of some stuff
and you know fairly decent and the other
thing get everyone kicked or is that
just Maxwell oh that's that's just such
a sauce that I agree fair that's just
the maximal time yeah I think I think
max is like a squire of all time we had
a few other new faces while we saw we
saw your own poison but we've also got a
few returning oh you wanna kiss oh oh no
no ok yeah ok yeah I want to you know
daddy capitec just to just to throw a
little bit
and the funny gay community is in effect
in the chat asking questions if you have
any questions I'd put them into gamespot
comments or in the twitch chat at jimbo1
1235 I was going to throw it in Joshua
it's just he released the Hollander man
why are hyper buffs dog back and extra
nerve supply to lower tier um so I'm
saying these words I imax not understand
okay so so basically what these people
are talking about is that there are some
buffs that went into these characters
that actually accelerated them from the
lowest of Tears yeah to the highest okay
and endings i guess like guile okay guy
who has always been pretty decent there
were some changes that were granted to
him that in the right hands would make
him pretty much unbeatable okay and you
know that's a concern to us because we
want to make sure that the game is
indeed balanced than fun so we actually
had to you know look at that and maybe
put in some new changes to address that
and of course you know people were
getting ready for these super characters
and they were like here it comes I'm
just gonna be invincible but you know
that's that's not valid so we had to
minimize some of those buffs those hyper
buffs as he said and you know give him
some nerves and nobody wants to see
nerves but you know if I'm the bearer of
bad news yeah you know I'll be it and
one of the I guess issues with with
fighting games a lot of the time is that
often publishers are trying to placate
the fighting game community but then
also sort of I guess make sure that
there's enough mainstream recognition of
it that they can like try and plug into
people might not be fighting games along
yes is this the sort of the fighting
game that's made purely for fighting
game fans do you feel like this is
not ignoring the main street do you
think like you guys are very much have
your eyes that I'm trying to make sure
the fighting game fans are satisfied
with anything else is kind of second we
tried to appease the boat you know so we
added in the new characters because the
casual guys they wanted to see new
characters they want to see the stages
they wanted to see something new they
wanted to feel like why should I come
back to street fighter 4 and we try to
placate that with a new characters in
touch with the hardcore players you know
it was them that we reached out to for
their feedback to give them the
character that they've always wanted to
play it's them who are gonna notice the
minor frame changes and property changes
and things like that but the casual
player won't so we're definitely not
turning a blind eye to the casual player
you know we trying to give everybody a
little something but I can definitely
say that uh hardcore guys are taking a
little bit more into account just
because this is a balance people all
right this is the the reason we went
back to create all trouble is to give
them what they wanted if they've made
this such a fair game then max why you
suck so hard oh well you know the
mysteries of my suckitude was ultra
street fighter 4 I say this signal here
without a controller right away yeah
wait I try to have you the joystick
tired though it's like hot potato you
take it back going definitely done not
for me we got our guys who can at least
put up a fight yeah we got a bunch of
the most of them were in that production
booth right Ned we have production cam
up hey no no no I'm we killed it
apparently so they could they can do
their job not wearing any clothes like
they used to yeah sure don't over window
and Elena here look at some of those
Joker's ever all right after this game
maybe see what happens dinosaurs yeah I
don't understand yeah this is definitely
one of the newer additions to ultra
street fighter Ford and not a couple of
questions coming in here
odyssey 413 gets super specific over
here do you think dhalsim will have the
to hit standing medium kick in the final
build uh I'd say that I say that they
have this personally I think guys have
to do [ __ ] yeah cuz I've even you
know he's definitely one of the tools
that are highly sought after but uh I
think you just have to wait until the
final changeless comes out okay the
window bill gets volume and we'll see
how amazing is it to be like responsible
for like you know sort of make gags one
not the fighting in communities perhaps
one of the like most passionate in terms
of your genre there are heavily in
gaming I guess first person tend to
fight each other's heads off other
genres you know sports tube8 the
fighting game community is the sort of
unique thing inside of gaming how
awesome is it to be representing them
for this franchise and also have much
pressure you know it's really awesome to
represent them because it's the first
time their voice has really been heard
anything development wise anything
development-related within Capcom but at
the same time it's really frustrating
because you know players really want to
win that's all you competitor
competitive right so fighting game
players they want to win so oh wow okay
oh nothing going on here I love this not
even giving them around you're not even
just gifts anymore no I that's have to
show what it's like to be a part of the
fighting HD no I'm sorry Stefan your
answer but uh yeah basically the players
I think they're like really passionate
they know what they want and if they
don't get it then sometimes they do get
a little bit and I've had to deal with
that for a little while but it's okay
though in the grand scheme of things I'm
just happy that
let's let you get a little bit of that
cherry so close oh that's going UT burn
to ashes in mouth oh alright just left
with the city I think yeah I think we
need a new challenge okay yeah I think
we need to bring in the ringer boys you
got fit either bring in the ring up
leader Benito Gonzalez I'm doll right
and you go oh technical director for the
lobby he's usually in there flicking the
switches but uh oh yeah we're gonna give
you some so nobody's picking a switch
the britax which is no not exactly
joystick and button switches but we're
gonna have to stick on this one camera
fee for the rest of the show because
he's there okay all right while your
student up I'm gonna ask you a couple of
more quick for our questions from the
community and arrow bukas asking are you
guys taking those to the japanese
release of us f4 in arcades yes we are
seeing with the player feedback is I
mean it is early impressions because the
game just came out a few weeks ago right
but if we do if we're looking for
anything that might particularly be
overpowered okay how do you think that
that's the changes you make will be
rolled back into the arcade stuff then
or is that sort of fixed in place where
we're definitely going to because
they're they're going to have the Capri
yeah be put on their stuff so we'll see
a way to make the people cool and Drake
the earth 90 do you think this will come
to next-gen consoles what are you
releasing on currently it's going to be
released on xbox and playstation 3 and
that's an early June at digital upgrade
and then the pc version the disc retail
version for both consoles will come out
in august and i noticed about this game
real quick gophers i play an outside 6
yes button so like the configuration and
this is like this is this a lifesaver to
you it is diamond outside haha so just
sees it the whole problematic you guys
don't there's a bunch of extra stuff in
that like you can do now except online
matches while you're in practice mode
exactly that was something highly sought
after by fans you know they want to make
sure that they keep their hands hot in
between matches and having them be able
to go to practice mode and practice
their convos while they wait for
somebody to come with me that
that's something that is just it just
makes your day because now there's no
cooldown time right when they're
searching between matches sometimes
they're just like I want to try that new
combo after they lose they're like all
right let me go back to practice mode
and test something out i love how you're
like comparing fighting gamers hands to
like tires on a NASCAR yeah like just
make sure just keep the tape choice and
no you yes Amelia you have to keep your
mind going like if you start you know
becoming complacent or something then
you're going to forget what it was you
were going to apply and get out of that
flow exactly yeah you just the last
thing you want to do ok so I'm going to
you to the dispatch janna sorry yeah
yeah but who are you Benito lots of
questions I'll your girl yeah I heard
he's okay so I gotta ask as many
questions as possible really confusing
one oh yeah out of nothing to do with
Street Fighter this is a great
opportunity if you guys to like the chat
to try to make up some real jargony
questions and so yeah I'm get Danny to
say them yeah do you think it's out of
myself thanks Chris yeah what is the
capital of Turkey yeah and what is the
airspeed velocity of an unladen will
frame data be available since so many
changes are happening whether online or
a strategy guide from bham 1630 from bum
ok oh yeah Creedy right now is working
on a kite ok so he should be on the top
of that will that be after launch do you
think it should we're saying you guys
are taking information from the arcades
and Japan is that telemetry data you're
getting like uploaded from the machines
or is that stuff that you're like on
forums and it it's yet done community
fees exactly ok so they're the ones who
know what's really abusable and all that
they'll easily find it back that's just
what they look for because they just
everybody wants to win right yeah that's
that's the point of a fighting game
exploit oh sorry back on and vs tv.com
do you think the character select screen
will be changed as well our flag is
coming back in I'm I don't think that'll
be the case here I think it'll it'll
look as you see it oh come on Benito
gazo pee in this version you gotta do it
knocking on the door back does it take
one oh so close oh yeah is it good hot
one round four games one small measure
of dignity all right now make a second
round one more remember Benito you're
playing for your job all right so then
you you lose to this earlier but of
course Combofiend you were at PAX fees
that are demolished the deficit event
taking on all comers for about an hour
long and had some tough matches there
one of the more unorthodox ones being a
force against Nintendo wolf oh yeah you
recall that match Oh completely yeah I
was I was just a little frightened to be
honest okay you know what was going on
behind the map you know behind them it's
tough to tell behind the map but the
focus competitor once the gloves came
off the pause still lost come on Benito
go got him ah we even did the Nintendo
wolf thing
yeah i was gonna get the screen I was
like yeah put it another way around i
took around you did you ground yeah I
think we need a new challenger yourself
is there a julio pack in the house so
what we got a julio pack out here man
running me through the gamma Tauri hey
oh this stream goes on for like forever
oh we're starting to talk to the bottom
eventually I'll get to play oh alright
nice work all right good stuff good
stuff i GG bonito y 0 ayn rand's look
he's happy like you did it I did it I
didn't lose his hard you're proud of you
back you do you need to set your buttons
at all I don't move them all more
questions Julio's getting this stuff
together and Vulcan Hades will the new
feature allow us to upload our videos to
YouTube where people you be able to
monetize videos uploaded this way it's
kind of a new thing and like every game
there people are asking but obviously
fighting game with tournaments and
one-off people wanted to share their
exploits yeah i mean if people are
watching i mean if you make something
from italy they look at you right yeah
just make sure that you get the word out
and people actually watch the videos
yeah there's no internal tool within the
games will I owe people to do after or
anything is there now these upload
whatever they want you know your matches
violent Buffalo violent Buffalo yeah I
don't know if l's a good choice for me I
should just listen to me yelling stuff
at you oh no no yeah I don't ago the
waiting for you to take for it but quake
asking will t-hawk of any tools against
Blanca I think that he has plenty of
tools now he has a faster walk speed
faster specials you know it's really up
to the player to make use of them right
I mean before it seemed really bad but
you tried to address thank you and Mike
pal pain is there any combo / juggle
potential for Cody and after normal Zonk
fadc I don't believe there is okay
currently I was hoping that was a
made-up one yeah
oh yeah this questions that you're
getting very extremely Technic what did
fadc me of focus attack bash council
okay Cena's arms like were playing
street fighter against my brother who
sucked yeah so I've never gotten to this
height of the game he didn't challenge
you to become a better player Danny used
to play on the Amiga 600 at which was
not the optimal way to play street
fighter shop say just say that mmm Phil
asks in regards to the arcade version
have there been any specific changes
brought to your attention for being
potentially too good for being
potentially yeah anyone overpowered as
far as on the right this is it hard to
like presumably when these games come
out first there are certain characters
who seem to be Opie but then after a bit
of time folks realize that there are
defensive measures against it yeah it's
always the grapplers so right now in the
Japanese arcade I believe that t-hawk is
one of those problem characters right
but I think that you know people can
fight him they're just not aware of what
are you doing so they fought for a lot
of stuff oh no I'm being redic look here
and a fake flash fire asks will DJ get
any more major changes it was reported
but there might be one last major change
uh I'll have to wait okay I've been pull
on that one Oh Combofiend does not apply
mercifully the arena and then clap you
that's pretty brutal you can teach you a
little fun oh they're days that's very
thoughtful of you oh he's trying it was
nice working with you